[Music]
on this tuesday night
growing impatience over the vaccine
rollout
the need for speed i think uh all
canadians
including me are frustrated to see
vaccines in
freezers and not in people's arms and
how some snowbirds are getting their
shot
now the rush for these spaces uh is
just yeah it's like a rollman stone's
concert
quebec's potential new curfew why
experts say
it's key to crushing the curve trivial
travel
during the pandemic they tell us that
we're all in this together but clearly
we were not
where is alberta's premier the push for
accountability
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
we were warned january would be a
difficult month in this pandemic and
just a few days in
it's not looking good new brunswick is
reporting its biggest daily spike
since the pandemic began in many other
provinces case numbers and
hospitalizations
are surging according to dr teresa dam
on average
nearly 7 500 canadians are now testing
positive for kova 19
daily and over the last week
approximately 122 canadians died from
the virus
every day in quebec there are reports
the government is considering a tougher
lockdown and curfews
in ontario there are new signs of a
health care system pushed to the limit
the province's first field hospital near
toronto
is now open to help ease the pressure
with the pandemic surging doctors are
warning canada's vaccination campaign
must be ramped up to get the situation
under control
the prime minister says he shares
frustrations about the pace
but he's optimistic i'm confident that
we're going to be able to get vaccines
to every canadian who wants them
by september that is certainly our goal
and we are we are very much on track
towards that
there's a lot riding on the timeline for
the vaccine rollo
we are all dependent on the shot to get
our lives back on track
in tonight's top story abigail beeman
looks at the criticisms
and how the government is responding
it's very stressful
every time i go to work every time i see
patients you know it's i'm definitely
thinking about it
dr dory schiff rolled up her sleeve
after signing a consent form saying
she'd get a second dose in 21 days
she didn't and she doesn't know when
she'll get shot too
quebec now getting all the vaccines out
the door for first doses instead
we consented to a two-dose vaccine we
didn't consent
to be to be given something that was
off-label
and we didn't consent to be part of an
experiment citing breach of contract a
lawyer for families at this montreal
care home is taking action
writing the quebec government in an
effort to get the residents at
maimonides geriatrics center their
second dose
i would like to really strongly
emphasize is that canada is committed to
a to those
vaccine regimens that is just one of
several vaccine issues across the
country
and while rollout is a provincial and
territorial responsibility it's the
federal government that has to get them
there
with some premier saying that's not
happening fast enough
canada has proven that we are ready for
a sustained tempo of vaccine deliveries
expected throughout the month of january
we have seen some challenges
he admits to challenges but prime
minister justin trudeau is confident all
canadians who want a vaccine can get one
by the fall
i think all canadians including me are
frustrated
to see vaccines in freezers and not in
people's arms
that's why we're going to continue
working closely with the provinces
trudeau announced a meeting with all
premiers thursday
rollout is on the agenda but he didn't
offer specifics of how ottawa will help
there are
many other ways of doing it other than
just through
hospital centers ontario greenlit a
pilot project in ottawa to get the
pfizer vaccine which needs to be stored
at ultra cold temperatures
inside long-term care homes with the
rollout at this one starting tuesday
the first site in the province outside a
hospital this will help save the lives
of those who are
most at risk and one day soon the
vaccine will be available to anyone in
ottawa who wishes to receive it
here in ottawa second doses of the
pfizer vaccine are
rolling out while the premier is
promising anyone connected to
long-term care in the hardest-hit
regions of this province
will be vaccinated by january 21st
abigail beeman global news ottawa
all levels of government seem to agree
vaccinations are a top priority in the
fight against covid19
but right now when compared to other
countries canada is falling behind
eric sorenson looks at the numbers and
what some provinces are doing
to speed up the rollout canada was ready
with open arms to receive the first
vaccines
and to show off the first vaccinations
but rolling out a mass
program is clearly a work in progress
barely a third have been jabbed so far
of the 420 000 doses sent to provinces
and territories
just 148 000 have been administered that
represents fewer than four people per
1000 canadians
the us and uk have vaccinated almost 14
per 1000
israel an astounding 158 per 1000
canada began receiving doses last month
and vaccinations began
but as more vaccines arrived the
challenge has been a growing gap between
vaccines distributed
and vaccines administered we clearly
need to pick up the pace and we need to
pick up the pace
rapidly we know that these vaccines
don't do any good in freezers they have
to be in
arms yes did we hit a couple bumps in
the road i'm always first to admit
when there's bumps in the road we get
through ontario's premier says the
biggest province is ironing out its
distribution bumps in a hurry the
province expects from pfizer biontech
tens of thousands of doses each week
this month plus
thousands more from moderna and it now
expects to exhaust the supply just as
quickly
once we get this shipment in thursday
for pfizer we're going to run out of it
again
the following weekend folks we're
ramping up
in winnipeg the manitoba government has
opened a supersite to speed up
vaccinations
and in nova scotia there are plans for
clinics across the province
what we've learned now in the first few
weeks will help us become more agile
in a few months when vaccines finally
arrive in huge numbers
many of canada's 11 000 pharmacies stand
ready
the head of one says altogether they
could vaccinate more than two million
canadians a week
our pharmacists are ready to do it we
have the processes in place
and we can handle this and are ready to
step up and help
as the pandemic surges governments at
all levels are urgently trying to get
vaccines distributed efficiently across
the country
so vulnerable populations followed by
all canadians
can get their shots as soon as possible
eric sorensen global news
toronto some canadian snowbirds
are skipping the line at home to get
their shots in the u.s
we'll explain later on global national
but first
quebec may have some of the tightest
kova 19 restrictions in the country but
things could be getting
tougher a strict lockdown over the
holidays doesn't appear to have slowed
the spread of the virus
the province recorded more than 2500 new
cases today
as mike armstrong reports the government
has delayed an announcement on new
measures
leaving quebecers wondering what's
coming next
if it's not open now it's likely not
opening for a while
quebec's premier was supposed to
announce new lockdown measures this
evening but pushed it back to wednesday
that's left families knowing there may
be a scramble coming
schools have been closed since december
17th kids are supposed to go back
in person monday next week i'm not sure
what i'm going to do
having to go back to work i think i'm
just going to have to take time off
now amid all the uncertainty there are
reports trickling out of quebec city
about what might be coming it's just
hard to say whether they're legitimate
leaks
or trial balloons testing what the
population might accept
but it sounds like a return to something
closer to the lockdown in march early in
the pandemic
construction sites would shut down again
offices and factories deemed
non-essential would be closed
bars restaurants and gyms would stay
closed as would stores
deemed non-essential they've been closed
since christmas day
i think for a short period of time it
was fine now we're talking about another
two to three weeks potentially
that's going to change the name of the
game also
likely to stay closed schools until
january 25th
that's something both the premier and
parents have been trying to avoid
nervous about the effect on children
well frankly i don't think we have any
other options at this point
epidemiologist chris labos is part of a
push to go
even further with the health care system
at the breaking point there are calls
for a curfew in france there's a
nationwide
nightly curfew from 8 pm to 6 a.m the
government of quebec is considering
something like that
and their support from experts half
measures they say
aren't enough it's too late we cannot
test more measure
we have to put in place very strict
measure and very effective measure
the idea wouldn't be to absolutely force
people to stay home with fines
but to at least make them think twice
whether going out was
absolutely necessary mike armstrong
global news
montreal new brunswick is tightening
restrictions after its biggest single
day increase of cases since the pandemic
began
the province recorded 27 new infections
in the last 24 hours
health officials say many are results of
holiday gatherings
this is not a good situation it has the
potential to get significantly worse in
the days ahead
we need everybody to actively get tested
if they have even the mildest of
symptoms of covet 19
and we need them to stay at home
as of midnight new brunswick will go
back to its orange alert level
that means face masks will be mandatory
in both indoor and
outdoor public spaces when physical
distancing of two meters can't be
maintained
residents will also be restricted to a
single household bubble
with exceptions for caregivers anyone
who gets sick with kova 19 will not be
able to use canada's sick leave benefit
if they've traveled outside the country
the prime minister says his government
is revising the rules to make it clear
vacationers aren't eligible we didn't
bring it in we didn't imagine when we
passed it unanimously in the house with
the support of all parties
that people would use it to pay for
their quarantines
after having gone south for a two-week
vacation
alberta premier jason kenney is staying
silent today a day after some members of
his government were disciplined for
their holiday travel
kenny hasn't spoken publicly about the
scandal since last friday
but as heather yorks-west explains all
eyes are on what the premier
does next between december 30th
and january 3rd while word was spreading
that several ucp mlas and a senior
staffer
had spent christmas break abroad 96
people in alberta
died of covet 19. one of them was health
care worker joe marie coral
he's a hero because he worked
he worked until he had called it in his
system
we feel shocked and um until now
we can't believe that he
uh he
can't believe that he's gone last
month's
rising case number seems to have
inspired albertans to do what is
required
a new leisure marketing survey has found
that many albertans say
they did follow gathering rules over
christmas 68 percent reported not
visiting anyone outside their household
that's compared to 52 percent of those
pools canada wide
the sacrifice of many over the holidays
comes in contrast
to beach vacations enjoyed by more than
half a dozen in provincial government
i do hope that the ucp has realized that
they have
will come out of touch with albertans
they tell us
that we're all in this together but
clearly we were not because of travel
restrictions
ironically tanya fur one of the mlas
caught traveling over christmas
made a video with the premier over the
summer asking albertans to spend their
vacations
at home the government has lost some
moral authority to ask us to
you know all make sacrifices together
and that's going to make it really hard
to enforce whatever restrictions are in
place
but the government will have to make
decisions very soon restrictions on
businesses announced in december are set
to expire at the end of this week
and while daily infection numbers have
been dropping reopening the economy
too fast could mean any progress made is
quickly lost
if we go back to what we were doing on
the scale in october and november we
will expect to see cases go up again
dramatically it's a tenuous position for
a premier that has seen his popularity
plummet
the need for an effective vaccine
rollout now more important
than ever before heather urex west
global news
calgary the frustrated airline industry
is scrambling to implement canada's new
covet 19 travel protocols
as of thursday any air traveler over the
age of five
will have to take a test within 72 hours
of their flight to canada
and provide the airlines with proof of a
negative result
the federal government rushed in the new
rule after the new more contagious
variant emerged in the uk but the head
of an organization representing major
airlines in this country
says the measure was put in place
without consultation or
a coordinated plan we have been
calling on the government now for six
months to work with industry to develop
the clear
strategy and implement a clear testing
strategy across the country
a negative test doesn't exempt anyone
from the mandatory 14-day quarantine
upon arrival
those who offer proof they couldn't
obtain a coven-19 test prior to travel
can still board a plane but they'll have
to isolate at federally approved
facilities
for two weeks westded has struck a deal
to sell some of its planes to amazon
the seattle-based retail giant is
purchasing four boeing 767
300 jets from the calgary-based airline
amazon also bought seven similar planes
from u.s carrier delta airlines
that will bring its amazon global air
fleet to 85 planes by the end of 2022.
amazon says it's the first time it has
bought planes for its delivery network
rather than leasing them the goal is to
rely less on postal and courier services
amazon did not reveal how much it's
paying west yet for the planes
a downpour with deadly consequences
coming up where roadways turned into
raging rivers
at least four people are dead in the
bolivian city of sucre
after flash floods saturated streets the
storm lasted only 30 minutes but
in addition to the intense rainfall hail
blocked storm drains during the downpour
reports say at least 10 people were
treated for hypothermia
it's election day in georgia the state
is holding a runoff vote for two senate
seats which will determine
whether democrats or republicans control
the u.s senate
the stakes are incredibly high and then
there's donald trump's relentless
campaign to cling to power
as jackson proskow reports he's using
tactics that have raised fears of
violent protests tomorrow
when congress meets to certify joe
biden's victory
in a state donald trump lost in november
voters returned to the polls to select
two senators
we're in the middle of a crisis where
we're losing thousands of americans per
day
the future of the country is on the
ballot here in georgia today
the stakes are so high that trump and
joe biden both visited the state monday
one state can chart the course
not just for the next four years but for
the next generation
trump quickly veered off script and
instead focused on his own election
defeat
people will remember the people that
don't support us the outgoing president
made more false claims about voter fraud
and false promises that his loyal vice
president mike pence
could overturn the will of voters when
congress meets wednesday to count the
certified electoral college votes
i hope that our great vice president
our great vice president comes through
for us he's a great guy
of course if he doesn't come through i
won't like him quite as much
by tuesday trump had pivoted to make
pence the bad guy
tweeting the vice president has the
power to reject fraudulently chosen
electors
that's just not true mike pence has
zero constitutional power he merely
reads the count of electors this is
something that president trump doesn't
understand
he sees no option at this point but to
go along and while some republican
members of congress plan to raise
objections
they don't have the votes to stop biden
from becoming president
in washington they're now bracing for
potentially violent protests as trump's
angry supporters flood the streets
to demand the election be overturned
the head of the far right proud boys was
arrested entering the city tuesday
charged with firearms offenses that
included carrying high-capacity
magazines adding fuel to the fire
president trump is already claiming
voter fraud in that georgia runoff
election before all the votes have even
been counted
and he's planning to speak to his own
crowd of angry supporters outside the
white house
during wednesday's protests robin
jackson prescott washington
still ahead calgary pays tribute to an
officer killed
on new year's eve
calgarians lined the streets today in a
somber tribute to a fallen officer
the police service encouraged people to
come out and pay their respects to
sergeant andrew harnett
a coffin carrying his body made its way
along the city's memorial drive
on route to a funeral home his
colleagues are struggling with the loss
of an officer
they knew as hardcore harnett a nickname
for his relentless dedication
to his work we're all hurting and we
really appreciate the
community support that we've seen the
blue lights
it's really meaningful harnett leaves
behind his wife who is expecting their
first child the 37-year-old officer was
conducting a traffic stop on new year's
eve when he was killed
two people have been charged with
first-degree murder
vaccination vacations up next the
snowbirds lured south
to get the shot
canadian snowbirds are facing a coveted
19 catch-22
should they wait to get vaccinated at
home or skip the line by flocking south
some states are giving shots to any
senior age 65 or older
and that offer extends to property
owners from canada
but as mike delay explains their ticket
to an early vaccine could come with a
price
their health the hottest ticket in
america
isn't just for americans after all
canadian snowbird george wolfe and his
american wife gigi guthrie
were among the first to get the kovid 19
vaccine in florida
the rush for these uh for these spaces
uh is
just yeah it's like a rolling stones
concert wolf has dual citizenship
but all he had to show to get the shot
was his driver's license
and this wasn't some loophole he took
advantage of because in
snowbird hot spots florida and arizona
anyone who owns property qualifies
but still it's a sensitive issue and
nobody wants to appear like they're
jumping the queue
including award-winning classical
guitarist leona boyd
i send you love in this time
the 71 year old says she rarely leaves
her palm beach condo
so she's eager for her turn wherever
that may be
but i mean if canada gets it first and i
i'm 71
so i'm definitely a senior i guess
i would fly back and get it whichever
country offers it first because i have
dual citizenship
and dual residencies i could really get
it anywhere
and it will likely be in florida where
more doses have been administered so far
than in all of canada
and the sunshine state has fewer people
to inoculate
all of it adds up to travel insurance
broker martin firestone seeing a sudden
surge in
calls from snowbirds inquiring about the
vaccine
yes he tells them it's legal but no they
shouldn't go
just for the shot the fear is if you get
sick from just
any one of the million and one things
you can get sick from as you do every
year when you buy travel insurance i'm
worried that the hospitals
are filling to capacity when asked about
so-called vaccine tourism today
prime minister justin trudeau was
succinct essentially saying
do it and you're on your own and that's
fine for canadians like george wolf
who says he's just following the rules
like everyone else
it's just a credit to gigi that she
found her way through the
this haphazard system to get in mike
hurley global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is smokey lake
county in alberta
we'd love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
you